yo what up this is Rich the kid the
biggest CEO you catch me on the bootleg
cam podcast
boo like cab show special guest in here
my guy man it's been a while we got Rich
the kid in the building
yes sir Rich what's up buddy yo big CEO
first of all uh it's been great to see
kind of like uh well congratulations on
the new record deal thank you I feel
like you've
hey man you know how to get a bag from a
label because I've seen you you was uh
originally an Interscope yeah and then I
want to say you went to Sony Columbia
was it was it
um Republic Republic yeah then there was
the Rostrum thing there was a little
Empire stop in there yeah and now where
you at RCA RCA okay yeah it's not you
know I can get the bags not really much
about the bag for me anymore I'm saying
it's like my support system and good
team I was gonna say because like that's
all happened in a very small amount of
time yeah like four years in four years
right so what is it about the fit for
you that because most artists one that
get stuck in a situation yeah right
where they sign and they owe a certain
amount you've been able to kind of get
in and out of situations pretty easily
since leaving Interscope yeah what what
give me the I guess the business behind
that and and the thought process
um you know just having them the best
support system you know just having a
team that's ready to shoot for you right
do you feel like that like once because
you know obviously being an Interscope
you had a lot of success in Interscope
new freezer plug tall I mean plug walk
we could go on and on and on
um
going from that and going through all
these different situations was it a
support system thing
um
when I was signed the nsco the the
person that signed me the endoscope they
ended up leaving after a while right
um so it was like you know I don't even
know this guy that happens a lot right
you'll get signed in a place and then
the person who believed in you leaves
and then there's new people who come in
and they're like well we didn't we
didn't sign you yeah so basically it was
like you know
just
the best support I just want whatever
the biggest artist in your label gets I
want that same exact treatment of course
so it's crazy because I think back to
the Interscope days and you had I
remember when new freezer first came out
there was not a lot of people are
getting Kendrick Lamar features in the
world yeah not a lot of people still not
a lot of people not a lot of people then
not a lot of people now very rare to get
a kdot feature especially I feel like he
really gave you one of them ones it's an
iconic record
talk me through that whole era getting
the Kendrick verse and was there ever a
point in time where you almost were on
TDE because there were some Rumblings of
that I feel like uh I I did something
so when you initially went to Interscope
it was through Top Dog yeah so I don't
think a lot of people know that yeah
so when I when I met Kendricks like I
was recording my app in one room
Kendrick recording his album one room
and scissor recording album another room
so it was like I'll record so everybody
was in the same building so it was easy
to just have him kind of walk over and
hear some [__]
um no at the time I didn't even know he
was recording there I just came and did
my [__] close the door right and then
one day they came in they're like yo
Kendrick wants to hear like some new
records
and then I played it in the new freezer
he's like yeah I need that yeah this one
but now I was waiting for the verse for
like a month because he was on the road
and doing shows and [__]
so I was like damn I just needed I need
attention first how'd you feel when you
got it when you heard it for the first
time
um you know
big accomplishment you know for for real
because before that I never had like a
hit song right that was your first like
big single yeah so I got signed pretty
much off of so when I got signed I was
signed to 300 ENT and I'm assigned to QC
records right and then like so I have to
like buy my way out so I never had no
hit so it's hard to get a lot of money
from a label when you have no streams so
I had to I had to pay QC 500 000 and I
had to give 300 300 000. plus I had to
get paid myself so you can imagine I had
a big deal signing my first deal so you
get the deal from Interscope and out of
that money you had to pay off QC and 300
300 and I had to get paid and you had to
still take some money home for yourself
yeah because at the time I was selling
QC and and not asked Pizza like you know
what I'm saying do my thing he's like I
need 500 000. and at the time I didn't
have five thousand dollars right you
know let alone 500. so I went in my
phone
and I called everybody from every label
every label that I had on my phone right
you know and
thank God I found one person
uh Manny Smith I'm shot through many
he's like yo come to the office
you know and then [__] it's history and
God God did the rest shout out to I mean
they let you buy yourself out at least
and they you know they believed in me
when I first jumped off the gate you
know what I'm saying for sure I mean a
lot of people kind of would equate you
to be like the fourth unofficial media
early on in your career because you're
on so many of those early records you
know yeah like me and Amigo were
dropping a lot of tapes and [__] before
they signed to qc2 so it was just like
we just hustling and working trying to
get our music heard you feel me how
close were you from like actually
joining the group though
Never Never Happened talk about losing
someone like take off man takeoff was
obviously a great guy he was one of the
nicest dudes you could ever meet in the
music game I mean you've known him for a
long time that had to be a big loss for
you
yeah you know it's my brother like my
best friend not my twin you know
everything
so it really [__] me I really never
lost nobody like that close
like and [__] me it's just like you know
you might just wake up and start crying
and see a picture start crying Here song
and start crying especially him like he
was such a just it felt like a very
peaceful genuine person yeah super nice
guy every time I met him he seemed like
you know he was and also like really one
of the most iconic bit influential
rappers ever if we think about his flow
and just like when I think of the Migos
flow I think I think it take off
legendary for sure yeah it's crazy man
like uh for you like was
um was that like a wake-up call to kind
of like you know because you never know
when you're gonna lose somebody these
days especially in the music game you
know
like I don't know if it was a wake-up
call but it's like you know it's just
crazy bro like
it just [__] me up you know
like
you don't know how to respond to
something you don't know like you don't
know I don't know does it make you move
a little bit differently in terms of how
you're moving around and you've had
situations where you've had some serious
[__] that could have went left we could
have lost you you know what I mean that
we know we all know about you know but
is when something like that happens do
you kind of like reassess how you're
moving who's around what you're into you
see me like I don't be with people I
just be by myself a [__] won't
even know where I'm at because I'm not
with nobody but right you know it's like
it's always it's always dangerous doing
anything in the rap and right being the
rapper
you got all this [__] for sure whatever
especially you moving around all that
jewelry
um can you take me back do you remember
when you first met take off and Amigos
because you guys literally came into the
game together you were forever be
synonymous with each other's careers
um
yeah I think it was amount of time I had
I had did a song with
um cash out from Atlanta and then I was
on the way to a show not from I ain't
really had no shows but I was on the way
to somebody else's show to go watch a
performance and they were like the whole
club ride I mean the whole car ride one
of my homies Peewee he was playing
nothing but the Migos tape
and I was like yo who the [__] like
don't think it's just walking right it's
going crazy
he like um the Migos they're from the
North side or whatever like yeah I'll
get you over there whatever I was like
cool whatever so the next day
I had I had took the CD from him so the
next day there's like a phone number on
the end of the CD it's like DJ Ray G he
was there DJ time I caught him like yo
where G I knew AG I'm like yo you [__]
with the Migos I'm trying to get up with
them [__] them [__] is hard he like
hell yeah we're gonna get in the studio
whatever yeah I was like bet so that
same night
it was like it's like a club in Atlanta
that used to be popping it's called
Mansion alone of course I went to that
club and then randomly I seen Ray G
outside the front of the club with the
Migos and he like yo this is the video
I'm talking about I'm saying we're gonna
link up and then we connected that night
and then like
two days later I went over to cuevos and
we just did history yeah like locked in
pretty much that's it that's crazy man
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our family at my
bookie that's right man look March
Madness is coming my favorite time of
the year to gamble is on the tournament
it's so much fun you just kind of close
your eyes
and uh you know win money uh all right
look if you want to try to get down go
to my bookie right now all right use the
promo code bootleg when you sign up for
a new account and you'll be able to
double your first deposit that's right
they're gonna match whatever amount of
money you put into up to a thousand
dollars so let's say you sign up right
now using that promo code bootleg in my
bookie put a hundred bucks in they're
gonna give you another 100 to play with
all right that's all we're doing over
here so many ways you can get money we
got the second half of the NBA season
here the Phoenix Suns are winning the
NBA Championship so put all your money
on that I'm not a professional when I
tell you to do that so if you lose your
money don't come at me bro I'm giving my
my unprofessional advice bet all your
money on the Phoenix Suns on my bookie
uh of course college basketball we got
baseball heating up spring training mess
so much happening and there's so many
ways to get money if you go to my bookie
right now that's mybookie.ag sign up
with the promo code bootleg and they
will double your first deposit right now
go do that plus Gotta Give a big shout
out to our family at hardean man you
already know hard Dean
Harding Las Vegas
yeah if you're in Las Vegas you need the
craziest selection of Premium cannabis
you've ever seen on this planet you got
to go to hard Dean all right man listen
Harding underscore Las Vegas on
Instagram go follow them right now if
you're in Vegas you got to pull up tell
them I sent you they're going to take
care of you uh when you walk in it just
you just get hit with that Hardy and
scent it smells so [__] good they got
the best selection of cannabis that
you're gonna see anywhere in the United
States it's pretty crazy all right plus
you can go get some of the fly marks
they got man go to hardinlasvegas.com
shoot them a follow man we uh we love
Harding my goodness they keep me high as
a giraffe's vagina all right listen go
to hardine underscore Las Vegas on
Instagram right now and go shoot them a
follow let's get back to the interview
um it's been dope to see the Resurgence
of
Rich Forever in terms of you know
it's good to see Dex doing well yeah you
know he has some low times that we all
are aware of uh and obviously Jay critch
has been eating for a long time for sure
yeah we've been working on the rich
rapper five well it's like pretty much
done now you know
and Jay Chris just put out his Juke
season project so it's just like
glue back to it you know what I'm saying
for you like being a CEO being kind of
the leader of the crew what what were
some of the things that you kind of had
to you know because I feel like we saw
Dex kind of struggle with his
sobriety you know staying in right right
state of mind and it seems like he's
doing really well now
for you was that something that was like
um hard to deal with like because you
know sometimes when I've I had a lot of
people in my life that have dealt with
addiction you know what I mean I know
that it's it's a heartbreaking thing to
go through yeah it's definitely
frustrating you know
like watching somebody like go to rehab
and then go back to it and then like
you know it's just frustrating but you
it's like my brother you're right it's
like honestly it's my artist but it's
like my real family and I'll be [__]
up if anything happened to him so it's
like I gotta put that first that
friendship you gotta put the human part
first before the artist should for the
industry should be good bro that was the
most important part to me yeah how how
far along is Rich Forever five is it
done or is it it's pretty much done yeah
we had like
um like
two weeks in the studio just locked in
is it just you three because I know you
have other okay
you know the fans been just wanting the
project from us three so
um
I'm about to see what what level I'm
gonna put it out through um
do you feel like you get enough credit
for being the CEO that you are man
because I do feel like if we kind of
rewind time in 2018 2019 like I was one
of the first CEOs yeah well I just mean
in terms of like you know I do feel like
Rich Forever is a movement I feel like
you guys got [__] plaques you guys
got numbers on the board you know what I
mean and I feel like uh sometimes maybe
people don't necessarily give you that
credit
um yeah man you know that's how I be a
lot of [__] don't get credit
for a lot of [__] true you know so
I'd be like
work harder nobody cares work hard you
know I'm saying that's why
I'm signing more artists I'm dropping
motion we got Rich Forever five dicks
guys project coming out I got my album
coming out you know what I'm saying so
gotta go harder man do you feel like um
you've also grown a lot in the last few
years because I feel like he was matured
a lot I feel like I see you moving a
little differently you know what I mean
I feel like it kind of in in terms of
just everybody kind of grows if you
stand the same you're [__] up you
know what I mean yeah for sure learn a
lot you learn a lot
you know you get hit with life for sure
because I see like obviously you and you
and young boy had a great project
together yeah did you I'm sure you saw
the interview you just did right here
kind of showed a lot of remorse for some
of the energy he put out into the world
yeah
um great interview great interview I was
gonna say like do you see that side of
him being someone who's like you know
that close with him because we don't
know young boy like he's kind of a
recluse you know even before he got
locked up I feel like like you know I
feel like
I feel like yeah people don't people
don't see a lot of sides him but you
know they now he's starting to open up
more for people so
so that's dope you know and he's Mormon
now
the fan he joined the church there I
think he's joining the Latter-Day Saints
Church yeah he's he lives in Utah
look you can't live in Utah too long and
not end up being a Mormon respectfully
they'll get you out there yeah I mean I
don't know much about it it's a solid
religion it's a yeah it is what it is uh
so what about your solo album obviously
you got a single out but what is
um I got an album that's coming out
um she had been working on it for like
two years so I ain't put out and so um
my last album was me and Lil Wayne
project so Jesus I forgot about that
yeah
so I ain't put out no album since then
so damn
I'm loaded I'm pretty much loaded right
now explain to me the little Wayne
project because that is not uh I mean
you obviously got your group [__] with
with the guys but then you got a young
boy album and then a little Wayne album
like
how does the Wayne thing happen like is
it just you guys get in and you guys
just are like yo this is crazy our
chemistry's so good we should do
something full or how does it work uh I
think I just you know I build a
relationship with two over the while I'm
saying we're good friends we chop it up
I talk to him like every week damn near
you feel me so
it's like
you know we just that's just like big
bro to me you know I'm saying so one day
he just hit me like let's put a project
together right I was like [__] you hell
yeah I can't wait yeah of course
whatever you want to do let's do it
so you know I might send him a record he
sent it back in like 30 minutes yeah
so pretty much like when we was
recording the project I might do a song
and I'm like oh yeah Wayne be hard on
this send it over he'll send it back to
me and then he'll send me one and then
like back and forth type [__] I was
gonna say like uh what's the difference
between doing an album with him and
doing an album with young boy is there a
difference there are creative processes
or
um
[__] like doing loud young boy I'll be
over at his house for like two weeks
we'll just be chilling there you know
what I'm saying so you guys would be
actually like fully locked in you're
locked in not leave right so do not move
Wayne I might come to the studio a
couple days or you know what I'm saying
shoot him some stuff through the email
get it back especially doing doing an
album with young boy he was on house
arrest he had just got out of jail right
and I went to his crib and we just
knocked out the album like was this when
he was in was this one in Utah no no
okay he was in um barrels okay okay yeah
yeah that's crazy that I didn't even I
forgot all about the Wayne album yeah
that's a big deal man not a lot of
people have Lil Wayne albums I don't
know if
besides Birdman father like son what is
another little wind collab album I don't
think there is one
like there's the Young Money album oh
yeah that's hard I think it's like just
you and Birdman have one of those nah I
think I think it's only Juelz Santana
but that wasn't that never came out
officially that leaked I can't feel my
face great [__] great [__] yeah shout
out to Dipset uh who's who's on this
album for you
um working on it for two years I'm sure
you got some heaters in
yeah I got
a lot of a lot of people now
um
little TJ on the album chat TJ you got a
song with him coming out Friday
um
Rambo's amazing ramble Rama Rama yeah oh
I don't know remember I thought he said
Rambo from here in L.A Rema yeah fob
artist okay I'm not hip Arya star not
hip put you on man I feel like you are
very ahead of the curve always
not for sure
um
who was I gonna help
I really gotta look at my list
because I really be want to be recording
so many songs when's the album come out
us this summer
so soon little TJ
summertime what's the name of the album
um Travis Barker on the album
um playing drums I'm assuming
Fabio J critch Jesus Meek Mills J Balvin
pop smoke Polo G
um the pop smoke first
Friday G herbo Friday
Jesus
sounds like a DJ Khaled album Jesus
and I got a couple girls on album too
but you know I can't give up everything
G herbo meek
pop smoke how old is the pop smoke
record was it when he was alive or did
you so you guys had Linked UP And yeah
me Papa smoking Polo G was in the studio
all three of us what was that like I was
though he was a light man he was an
internet oh my God man
is it harder to get something like that
cleared when like obviously you got to
clear it through the estate or through
his label because obviously he's not
here anymore you know and I'm sure
you're not the only one who's got old
pop smoke songs before he passed you
know it was a process probably yeah yeah
how's the record though is it crazy this
year you you pop smoke Polo G you all
through us oh [__] oh yeah this album's
gonna be crazy is it just you and Meek
Mill in the meek record is it yeah yo
that dude Friday's voice is insane
Friday is hard I [__] with him too his
voice I saw him record that God did [__]
on his computer did you see that video
that [__] was crazy this voice is like
that [__] is wild damn so you got he did
a record with us on the Rich Forever
products too she had a couple of Friday
joints on two
damn you got some features shout out to
G herbo too I can't wait to hear it yeah
man hey we got to stop the interview to
tell you about our good Folks at Blue
chew baby that's right A lot of people
keep asking me does Bluetooth work [__]
yeah it does and if you don't believe me
they'll give you a whole month for free
right now if you go to bluetooth.com and
use that promo code bootleg that's
bootry.com promo code bootleg you get a
month of blue chew for free delivered to
your [__] house all you do is pay
five dollars in shipping what is blue
tree you ask well let me tell you it has
the same active ingredient as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable tablet but it is
discreetly delivered right to your
doorstep no awkward doctor's visits
imagine going and telling uh an old guy
about your dick
you would prefer not to do that I know
I'd prefer not to do that you know but
you could do it all online bluetooth.com
you don't have to go to the doctor's
appointment in person no more no they're
going to send it straight to your door
all right your wife won't even know it
came your wife won't know
that you came and it came all right so
what you do is
you uh you go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg and you get a month
of uh the whole thing for free that's
right a month supply of Bluetooth for
free straight to your door they also
just dropped their new mint chewable
which is the same exact active
ingredient as Levitra so many options
for you at Bluetooth to make sure your
dick is right going into the springtime
baby look spring break's coming uh are
you gonna be coming
the real question is
is your partner going to be coming
not with the noodle dick
let's be honest make sure that shit's
hard as [__]
go to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg and get a month's supply for
free and if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it's okay man
it happens to the best of us go to
Bluetooth and put a Band-Aid on that
thing bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
also
while we're talking about our partners
shout out to our family at Odd Socks oh
look at these Odd Socks underwear man
they're they're Half Baked
so much going on at Odd Socks uh so many
dope licenses man shout out to uh they
got Cheetos they got Jaws [__] Oreos
Cheech and Chong Naruto WWE by the way
WrestleMania is coming I can't wait to
see what dope WrestleMania socks they do
this year because last year they knocked
it out the park at Odd Socks look the
most comfortable socks in the world they
got the odd Sox Basics that you need on
your feet uh all you gotta do is go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use the
promo code bootleg at checkout you'll
save 20 off your total order underwear
socks
[__] hats whatever you need they got it
at Odd Socks uh they just got the
Coca-Cola deal so you go get some
Coca-Cola drawers Coca-Cola socks so
much always going on in Odd Socks I'm
gonna always say my favorites are the
WWE in the Breaking Bad Ones
um so go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you will
save 20 off at checkout shout out to
them most comfortable socks in the world
crazy comfortable underwear my goodness
if you ain't got Odd Socks on your feet
and ass what are you doing out in these
streets all right go to
hotsocksofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off let's get back to the
interview
um all right well look rich what's
coming first your album or Rich Forever
five
um
hopefully Reserve five times up there
ASAP um yeah that that'll be soon yeah
soon don't know where from like like
Homewise yeah
um yeah you know because
figuring it out you know it's new
independent
major
um
it's a new projects still sitting with
it right now I mean Jay critch is that
Empire yeah well maybe do the Empire
thing yeah yeah I [__] with Empire heavy
yeah look I gotta let me ask you this
Rich because as somebody who has seen
every kind of side of the music industry
there's just like a
conversation out there nowadays that
um
indep being independent is better than
being on a major I wouldn't say that I
wouldn't say I was gonna say you've seen
it all as being better I would say
independent is cool it depends on what
you care about really you know what I'm
saying
you care about just getting the money or
you care about just having these dreams
because you know you gotta think about
it
you gotta have a machine to run this
[__] right
and being independent in school he just
takes a lot of work a lot more work
right a lot more of your own money yeah
so if you're maybe not in a position
financially to do certain things you
could use the labels money
yeah but it is not only money is
relationships too you know what I'm
saying these latest labels have been
building relationships for 20 30 years
it's not it's not like anybody can just
get a rap caviar yeah you know for sure
dead ass dead ass for real yeah and if
you're independent it's probably going
to be a lot harder to get in rep career
then it's a bigger uphill battle to do
everything for sure yeah for sure and
then I saw like there's like because
okay I'm assuming every one of these
deals you've had since you left
Interscope you get in advance right
I think that there is a narrative out
there
that isn't all the way accurate that if
you get an advance it has to be recouped
before you could leave that's not the
case right
um everybody's deal is different okay
you know my deal is not structured the
same as these artists these days because
a lot of times I think you could I mean
if like you said if you have the right
structure you should be able to get the
the label giving you that Advance is a
gamble on their side
it's not like you have this like [__]
hanging over your personal credit I've
been seeing all these like misleading
videos about people saying like an
advance is the worst loan you can ever
take out well it's not really a loan
because it's not on your personal credit
like if you pay it back cool if your
music it recoups cool but it's also a
risk I've never been like
this type of artist there wasn't able to
recoup you feel what I'm saying so I
never really had a tough
you're recouped everywhere I never
really had the tough problem where you
if you're making hits then
you probably [__] you really well I was
gonna say when you see someone like QC
and uh and those guys sell for 300
million dollars that was fire
huge considering you were there when it
first was started up like uh that's
amazing bro what do you think is going
on where everyone seems to be selling
right now
QC sold everyone's selling their
publishing well so I'll be seeing
everyone in there I mean
uh you know future soldiers oh yeah
selling publishing
that's like a common thing though like
[__] do that [__] all the time like
when they first get their first hit and
they might sign a publishing but it's
like people are selling their satellite
catalog yeah yeah they're selling their
catalogs catalog Justin Bieber is so I
think I think he had 200 million you
know that's smart for some people like
after you've been in the game for a long
time like you've ate off of it for all
these years already yeah you've been in
the game for a long enough time
it's it might be smart to sell a catalog
but you just coming in and you thank you
for the damn tele catalog I'm folks
ain't gonna give you nothing would you
sell your catalog uh I'm chilling right
now you're chilling I'm chilling right
now I got a whole album about to drop
yeah I'm saying my structure with my
neighbor and stuff like that I'm just
good you know what I'm saying it's like
I'm not in no [__] so that's what's
up man uh new album hopefully soon Rich
Forever five much sooner yeah uh shout
out to Jay critch any any what's going
on with uh with uh Dex house he's doing
good man he's on tour right now and um
he got a new single coming out too so
yeah
we're [__] worth 300 of course shout
out to 300 man shout out to my guy happy
birthday to my guy Shadow over there
just some shadow shadow the legend man
well Rich the kid I appreciate you
pulling up brother you already know new
album on the way yes I might smoke some
of this [__] yes sir